There's a psychologist named piaget,
some of you might know about him.
Piaget was very interested in what
happens to value structures and their
hierarchical organization once they have
to apply outside of the confines of a
body.
So,
so here's a way of thinking about it.
Two year olds basically hypothalamic.
That's why there's so much fun.
First they're happy,
then they're sad,
they're hungry,
then they're tired,
you know,
they just zipped from one pretty
straightforward and rather are inspiring
motivational state to another and but at
two they can't play.
They can play with by themselves,
but they can't play with other children.
They can't get that until they're three
and they need to get it by the time
they're three because if they don't get
it by the time,
therefore they will never get it.
And then you have an antisocial kid
who's going to be an outsider for his
entire life and there isn't anything you
can do about it.
So that has to happen between two and
four.
So what happens at about age three is
that the kid learns how to play a game
with another person.
And what that game is,
is fundamentally the development of the
ability to share a frame of reference,
which is what you're doing when you play
monopoly.
It's like it's stupid to play monopoly,
obviously,
who cares if you have a whole pile of
counterfeit paper,
right?
But doesn't matter because the way your
constituted is that your brain will
treat anything you acting like
constitutes a valuable goal as if it's a
valid framework of reference.
And if it couldn't do that,
a,
you couldn't abstract and B,
you could not get along with other
people.
So you can sit around the table and you
can say,
let's pretend that monopoly is a
reasonable facsimile of reality,
which you wouldn't say,
but it's what you mean.
And everybody says yes,
that would be a music.
And so then you set your goal,
which is to get all the little hotels
and all the money and Poof,
your emotions go along for the ride.
And what's so interesting about that is
you can get everybody into the game.
And so one of the things that's really
interesting about people is that we can
establish a shared fictional frame of
reference and it organizes all our
emotions.
So they're predictable.
That's also why we can watch movies.
You go to a movie,
you identify the hero,
you figure out what the hero wants,
proof you're the hero.
And the way that works is you don't look
at the hero and think about what he's
doing and evaluated emotionally and then
feel it.
What you do is you specify the hero's
goal and then you map them onto your
body and you read off the emotional
responses of your own body.
And that's how you understand the hero.
So it's an embodied,
you're,
you're using your,
your embodiment as a computational
device that can run simulations of other
consciousnesses.
And it does that with the body.
And we like doing that.
You can go to a movie and you know,
you're Brad Pitt for an hour and a half.
You know,
when you're Brad Pitt doing remarkable
things.
And that's also how we understand other
people were very good at that.
So anyways,
we have these shared frames of reference
like when we're playing monopoly,
okay,
so children at three learn how to play
games and that means they learn how to
organize their own internal motivational
states into a hierarchy that includes
the motivational states of other people
and that means they can play.
And that's what you guys do when you're
out in the world.
Like we're playing a game right now.
We all know the rules.
That's why we can all sit in this room
and play the game without fighting with
each other.
You know,
in the room is set up like a theater and
we all know the theater game and so.
And the chairs are all facing this way
at the moment.
And so that's a hint that you should
look forward and this is raised so you
know the room is basically telling you
what to do because it's a stage like all
rooms and because you're smart and
socially conscious,
you can walk into a stage room and your
body knows what to do and if you're
civilized and social you just do it.
Then all the other primates can predict
what you're up to and they won't kill
you.
Yeah,
well that's what it means to be part of
the same tribe.
You know when people are very peculiar
creatures and God only knows what
they're up to,
but as long as they're playing the same
game you are.
You don't have to know what they're up
to because you can predict what they're
going to do and you understand their
motivational states and so part of the
building and constructing of higher
order motive,
higher order moral goals is the
establishment of joint frames of
reference that allow multiple people to
pursue the goals that they're interested
in simultaneously and then what you have
to think about with regards to that is
that not all shared frames of reference
can manage that.
There's a small subset of them that are
optimized so that not only can multiple
people play them,
but multiple people can play them and
enjoy them and do it repeatedly across a
long period of time.
So it's integratability that partly
defines the utility of a higher order
moral structure and that is not
arbitrary.
It's an emergent property of biological
interactions and you might say,
well,
it's kind of arbitrary because people
can do what they want,
but it's not arbitrary at all because a
lot of what's constraining your games is
your motivational substructure and those
ancient circuits that are status
oriented and they operate within
virtually every animal has a status.
Counter creatures organize themselves
into dominance hierarchies.
The reason they do that is because that
works.
It's a solution.
It's a solution to the Darwinian problem
of existence.
It's not just the nap and phenomena,
it's the real thing.
So you,
your environment,
fundamentally a huge chunk of your
environment is dominance hierarchy plus
God only knows where you are and that's
the order in chaos and part of the
reason that people fight to preserve
their dominance hierarchies is because
it's better to be a slave.
Who knows what the hell is going on than
someone who's thrown screaming and naked
into the jungle night and that's the
difference between order and chaos and
we like order better than chaos and it's
no wonder now we'll invite a little
chaos in for entertainment now and then,
but it has to be done voluntarily.
And generally you don't want the kind of
chaos that upsets your entire conceptual
structure.
You know,
you're willing to fool around on the
fringes a little bit,
but you know when the going gets
serious,
you're pretty much likely to bail out
and no wonder.